FOLLOW US AT STEVE HILTON ACTS
AND THAT NEXT READ FNC AND
ASSURED WHERE WHEN WE POSTED
TOMORROW.
JAMIE NOW DOCTOR MARC SIEGEL.
MARK, LET ME BUT DO YOU
FOLLOWING ON FROM WHAT I JUST
SAID OPEN WHERE POSSIBLE, CLOSE
WHERE NECESSARY.
I THINK THE CENTRAL QUESTION
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
PUTTING TO ME WHEN YOU HEAR IT
ALL THE TIME WHICH IS WHY CAN’T
WE JUST PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
AND EVERYONE ELSE CAN GO ON WITH
THEIR LIVES?
THAT WAS BEING REJECTED BY
SOMEONE AND I WANT TO REDO THIS
QUOTE AND I ASK YOU TO RESPOND
WITH ARTICLE IN THE ATLANTIC AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE LOOKING OUT
WHICH IS HOW DOES THE
CORONAVIRUS AND?
HIGH-RISK PEOPLE SUCH AS THE
ELDERLY COULD BE PROTECTED WHILE
LOWER RISK PEOPLE ALLOWED TO GO
BACK TO WORK.
SUCH THINKING IS SEDUCTIVE BUT
FLAWED AND IT’S OVERESTIMATES
OUR ABILITY TO ASSESS A PERSON’S
RISK AND TO SOMEHOW WARD OFF THE
HIGH-RISK PEOPLE FROM THE REST
OF SOCIETY.
WHY IS THAT FLAWED?
WHY CAN’T WE DO A MORE TARGETED
STRATEGY?
>> STEVE, I THINK WE CAN DO A
MORE TARGETED STRATEGY.
THAT ARGUMENT IS FLAWED BUT
THERE IS A MISSING PIECE THAT I
WANT TO BRING UP TO YOU.
IT IS CALLED RAPID POINT-OF-CARE
TESTING AND WE NOW HAVE IT.
AVID PUT OUT A TEST THEY CLAIM
THEY CAN TEST 50000 PEOPLE A DAY
AND IT’S IN A SMALL FOX AND YOU
GO TO IT AND TO A TINY NASAL
SWAB, NOT THE BIG CUMBERSOME
THING WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
AND FIVE, 13 MINUTES LATER THEY
TELL YOU WHETHER YOU HAVE
COVID-19 OR NOT.
THAT IS THE FIRST ANSWER TO THIS
QUESTION.
IF I KNOW PEOPLE DON’T HAVE IT I
FEEL MUCH MORE SECURE ABOUT THEM
GOING TO WORK OBVIOUSLY.
IF I KNOW THEY DO HAVE IT MAYBE
I CAN USE UNIVERSITIES THAT ARE
NOW SHOT OR HOTELS OR HAVE THEM
SHELTER IN PLACE AT HOME IF THEY
CAN DO THAT SAFELY.
I CAN SELECT THEM OUT FROM THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE TO LET PEOPLE
WHO DON’T HAVE COVID-19 GO BACK
TO WORK.
THE FLAWED ARGUMENT IS BASICALLY
SAYING IF WE DON’T KNOW WHO HAS
IT THEN WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
YOUNG PEOPLE OR HEALTHY PEOPLE
AS TYPHOID MARY’S AND THEY MAKE
SPREAD TO A HIGHER RISK GROUP
THAT IS TIME NOW FOR THAT
THINKING IN THE BLIND TO GO
AWAY.
WE CAN TELL WHO HAS NOW AND WE
CAN TEST WIDER GROUPS OF PEOPLE.
STEVE: DO THINK THAT COULD BE
RAMPED UP SUFFICIENTLY IN THE
NEXT MONTH?
WE HAVE THIS EXTRA MONTH WITH
THE EXTENSION OF THE GUIDELINES
WITH IT BEING ANNOUNCED TODAY
AND DOES NOT GIVE US ENOUGH TIME
TO GET TO THAT POINT BUT THE
TESTING?
>> I THINK IT BETTER BUT I THINK
WE WILL PUT EMPHASIS ON THAT
TONIGHT AND I THINK IT WILL EVER
THINK WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PRAY I WANT TO SAY TO OTHER
THINGS FIRST, I WANT TO ECHO
YOUR POINT ABOUT SUICIDE BECAUSE
UNEMPLOYMENT AND PANDEMICS ARE
BOTH HIGH RISK OF SUICIDE WITH
HIGH RISK OF DEPRESSION.
IT IS WHAT WE CALL COLLATERAL
DAMAGE IN MEDICINE.
IT’S SO IMPORTANT THAT YOU ARE
FOCUSING ON THAT TONIGHT AND
THAT PEOPLE WITH A VERY NARROW
VISION IGNORE THAT BUT THAT IS
THE OVERALL DAMAGE DONE TO THE
SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
IN ADDITION TO THE TEST I TALKED
ABOUT WE NOW HAVE A BLOOD TEST
THAT HENRY HAS PUT OUT THAT CAN
TELL US WHO IS IMMUNE AND WHO IS
NOT IMMUNE SO LITERALLY SOMEBODY
WALKING AROUND WITH IMMUNITY TO
THE CYRUS OR WHO HAD IT BEFORE
AND WE NOW KNOW THEY ARE OVER IT
IN A WAY THEY ARE A PROTECTIVE
GROUP AND I GROUP COULD
CERTAINLY GET BACK TO WORK IF
YOU HAD YOUR IMMUNE CELLS AND
HAVE ANTIBODIES TO THE VIRUS WE
KNOW YOU HAD IT WE KNOW YOU ARE
OVER IT AND YOU CAN GO BACK TO
WORK.
THESE TESTS ARE CRUCIAL TO
FLYING IN THE FACE OF WHAT THE
ATLANTIC IS TRYING TO SAY.
THEY ARE WRONG AND PROVIDED THAT
I HAD THE INFORMATION I NEED AND
I THINK I CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION VERY RAPIDLY.
I THINK WE HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY
AND ITS TIME OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WORKS WITH THE WAY IT IS
SUPPOSED TO.
THE PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP
HERE AND FINALLY THE FDA HAS
APPROVED THESE TWO TESTS.
IT TOOK TOO LONG AND NOW IS THE
TIME TO GET IT WIDELY
CIRCULATED.
BOTH OF THESE TESTS, ONE A BLOOD
TEST AND 18 NASAL SWAB.
STEVE: JUST TO WRAP IT UP THERE,
OPEN WHERE POSSIBLE, CLOSE WERE
NECESSARY, SOUNDS LIKE YOU
SUPPORT THAT STRATEGY BUT IT
ONLY WORKS IF YOU HAVE
WIDESPREAD TESTING, NOT JUST OF
THOSE PEOPLE WITH SYMPTOMS BUT
OF EVERYONE.
HIS DAD - AND MY UNDERSTANDING
YOU CORRECTLY?
>> I WANT TO QUALIFY THAT AND
SAY TWO THINGS.
EVERYONE WHO MAY HAVE IT OR MAY
HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
SOMEONE WHO HAD IT AND THAT IS
THE GROUP I WANT TESTED.
COULD YOU HAVE IT, TO HAVE THAT
COUGH, SHORTNESS OF BREATH, DO
YOU HAVE SYMPTOMS I’M CONCERNED
ABOUT AND WHO ARE YOU IN CONTACT
WITH.
THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE
AND THIS IS WHAT YOU PROBABLY
AGREE WITH ME, WE NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT THESE EPICENTERS.
IF I CONTEST AROUND THE
EPICENTERS THE HOT ZONES WE ARE
CALLING THEM, MAYBE IN THE
MIDDLE OF MONTANA YOU ARE OKAY
AND CAN GO BACK TO WORK AND
MAYBE IN THE RURAL AREAS OR
WHERE THE VIRUS IS NOT HITTING
BUT 19 STATES HAVE NOT SEEN
MAJOR CASES HERE.
THOSE PLACES SHOULD CERTAINLY BE
REOPENED IF WE CAN BE SURE THAT
THEY DON’T HAVE VIRUS.
ABSOLUTELY.
STEVE: GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EXPERTISE ON
THIS TONIGHT AND EVERY DAY AND